Good evening everyone. I now call to
order this May 27th, 2025 meeting of the
Lancaster City Council. A few reminders
for everyone at the top of the meeting.
This meeting and its participants are
being recorded. Please take a moment to
silence your phones and devices if you
haven't done so already.
I'll make a note that this evening at
5:30 p.m. members of council attended an
information session with the city
solicitor during which he provided us
with information regarding executive
orders issued by President Trump and
actions taken by various federal
agencies. During our meeting this
evening, there will be several
opportunities for public comment. The
first public comment period is for
residents that have registered in
advance to speak about items not on the
agenda. Residents may also comment on
individual items on our legislative
agenda. That's item nine uh on our
agenda this evening. Finally, a second
public comment period will be at the end
of the agenda for any other speakers
wishing to address council. All speakers
should begin with their name and block
of residence for our meeting record. And
uh please be advised that public comment
is not a question and answer period. All
comments are limited to three minutes
per speaker. And to keep time, I'll be
using this light here. It will turn
green when three minutes begins. It will
flash yellow when there's one minute
remaining and then turn red after 3
minutes. After 3 minutes has been
expended, we will I will ask speakers to
end their comment. And I appreciate
everyone's cooperation in order to
maintain order and equal time. And
lastly, speakers addressing city council
and members of the audience are expected
to conduct themselves in an orderly
manner and remain respectful of others.
Thank you in advance for doing that.
Now, for all of those who are willing
and able, please rise for the pledge of
allegiance.
I aliance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the for it
stands one nation under God indivisible
with liberty and justice for all.
Mr. Harris, would you please call the
role of members? Yes, Madam President.
Mr. Med here. Mr. Roya here. Mr. Glee
here. Miss Craig here. Miss Diaz, Mr.
Hirs here, President Baker here.
Our next item is the approval of the
minutes of our May 13, 2025 meeting.
Motion to approve. Second. We have a
motion and a second for the meeting
minutes. Are there any council comments
on the
minutes? Hearing none. Mr. Harris,
Mr. Mr. M. I. Mr. Royer. I. Mr. Glee. I.
Miss Craig. I. Mr. Hersh I and President
Beke I.
Next item on the agenda this evening are
proclamations, honors, awards, and
resolutions of recognition. We have one
of those this evening. Uh Mr. Harris, if
you would please. Resolution number 34.
Yes, Madam President. a resolution of
the council of the city of Lancaster
recognizing Asian-American, Native
Hawaiian, and Pacific Islander Heritage
Month and the contributions with which
Asian-Americans, Native Hawaiians, and
Pacific Islanders have made to the city
of Lancaster. Motion to approve. Second.
Thank you. We have a motion and a
second. Councilors, let me uh welcome up
this evening members of the Lancaster
AAPI who will be speaking on behalf of
this resolution this
evening. Good evening and thank you for
being here. Since you're the first at
the microphone, I'll just say make sure
that you see the light is on. You may
have to hit the button and you may move
that microphone up and down as needed.
And you do need to be pretty close with
this speaker system we're using, so
don't be afraid. Is this good? Okay.
Thank you. Good evening. Welcome. Good
evening. Thank you so much for having
us. Um, thank you for giving me the
chance to speak tonight. My name is
Cindy Lamb. I am the president of
Lanster API. I'm also the coowner of um,
Cilantro Asian Street Kitchen. Um, you
may or may not know on every corner and
every block of Lancaster City, every
road, every shopping center in the
county, up and down Route 30, every
traffic line street off the beaten
paths, small roads to major highways,
there is an AAPI owned
business. During the height of CO 19
pandemic, many businesses stores
shuttered. So many of our Asian-owned
businesses stayed standing, not because
it was easy, but because we refused to
give up. We brave through difficult
social and economic times. We adapted
and pushed forward because we're a
resilient community. But resilience
doesn't mean the road has been easy.
Even today in 2025, the climate for
small businesses, especially minority
minorityowned businesses, has grown more
challenging. Inflation, rising costs,
labor shortages, and new waves of bias
and xenophobia continue to test us. Our
community faces obstacles that go go
beyond the economy, once rooted in
perception, misunderstanding, and
sometimes unequal access to
opportunity. We are also navigating a
climate where immigrants and immigrant
families, many within our AA and HPI
community, are often treated with
suspicion, dismissed, or even targeted.
In times like these, it's important to
remind everyone here. Many of us through
grandparents or parents came here out of
courage. We came here to work hard and
build a life and we chose Lancaster as
our home. Many of us have chosen to
build businesses here, to invest in the
city, to raise our families here and
share our culture with everyone. The
AHPI community has poured their hearts
into building a vibrant and thriving
community. And our impact can be felt in
every corner of this city. We enrich the
cultural fabric of Lancaster with every
dish, every service, and every story
that we share. By recognizing and
honoring a NH and HPI Heritage Month,
you're saying that we see you, we value
you, and we believe in your place here.
So, thank you for that. You help create
space for our stories to be told, our
cultures to be shared, and our futures
to be built together. You're supporting
families who bet everything on a better
future. And you're supporting neighbors
who are helping to shape Lancaster's
economy, culture, and heart. Let's
continue to be intentional and about
recognizing, honoring the strength and
sacrifices and contributions of the
AANHPI community. I ask for all of us
and our city council leaders to continue
to uplift, honor, and invest in our
stories, in our voices, not just in May,
but every month of the year. Because our
stories don't begin and end with a
heritage month. They are written every
single day here, right here in Lancaster
City. Thank you for walking with us,
standing with us, and celebrating all
that we are. And I would like to
introduce the next speaker from
Lancaster API, Rachel. Thank you. Thank
you.
Hello. Excuse me. Hello. Well, my name
is Rachel Yung. I was recently made
Lapy's new Avenge Chair. Um, I just
wanted to give a little background on
me. So, I'm originally from Harrisburg,
PA. Actually, um, I come from a really
traditional Vietnamese family. And they
both on both sides, they settled in the
US as refugees because of the war. And
so, growing up in central PA, the
dichotomy of being Vietnamese American
has definitely been a roller coaster. I
attended a private school in Harrisburg
throughout high school and then went to
Lebanon Valley College. So, I have grown
really accustomed to navigating white
centric spaces and standing out so much
that I often felt like I had to hide
just how different my family and I were
um in order to struggle just to fit in.
And being Asian, my identity within
these spaces was often already decided
for me before I even stepped foot in the
room. Looking back, I faced daily micro
macroaggressions that I didn't even
understand at the time. And a lot of
those experiences really shaped how I
saw myself because I could not fully
embrace my identity. And I just felt
self-conscious because I wasn't the norm
all the time. I often found myself
craving community with people who looked
like me and shared similar cultural
experiences. In college, I was
introduced to more socially conscious
studies that really opened my eyes to
what was going on. and I finally felt
seen. Hearing other marginalized people
and students speak on their experiences
and how they overcame those barriers to
become outspoken advocates in their
communities really empowered me and lit
a fire in me that I've carried
throughout my life
since. So that's why I sought out LAPY a
few years ago when I moved to Lancaster
in 2020 in the midst of the pandemic. It
was a crucial time in a lot of
Asian-Americans lives. And at the
suggestion of a really good friend who
saw that I was seeking community because
I felt so
alone, she introduced me to individuals
from Lappy and they accepted me with
open, loving arms. And I've been so
grateful ever since because now I get to
work within a space with such wonderful
individuals that empathize with and
uplift my passions for social advocacy
and representation.
Being part of this organization has
opened so many doors for me to connect
with other people from other
multicultural organizations as well that
represent the rich diversity of people
here in Lancaster and help expand my
world view. My lived experience in
Lancaster so far reminds me to stay
grateful to come from such a beautiful
culture that affords me the wonderful
experiences of connecting with so many
others that now make up my beloved
community. Witnessing the efforts that
have been made in Lancaster to embrace
the A&HPI population that resides here
and celebrates our cultures and
relevance in the city has been truly
empowering. I'm very proud to be part of
this community now and I'm excited to
see how we continue to grow. Thank you
all very much.
[Applause]
My name is Samuel Solomon. I lived here
in Lancaster, PA since I was one year
old. I'm a Macy alum, photographer,
coowner of a street wear clothing brand,
and a board member for an organization
called Touchstone Foundation working to
support youth mental health here in our
city. While living in America, I've been
under a program called DACA, which
stands for Deferred Action for Childhood
Arrivals. For half of my life, I've been
living in this legal limbo along with
over half a million children of
immigrant parents. We are granted
temporary protection from deportation
and the ability to live and work here in
the United States legally. We have to
apply to renew the status every two
years with no pathway to American
citizenship. I've built my whole life
here, working, paying taxes, and trying
to make a positive impact in my
community. Yet, there's no guarantee if
I can stay here in America. Despite
living in this legal limbo for over 10
years, I'm really proud to call Langster
my
home. This past year has been a journey
of reflection where I ask myself if I
truly fit in and if I truly belong. But
Langster has always Langster has always
been shaped by immigrants and people
like me are a part of that
legacy. Since its founding, Langster has
had over 250 years of welcoming
immigrants and settlers. Those who seek
to find a better life and help build up
this community and this country. Today I
find myself in fear of how people like
myself are seen and what is happening to
immigrants in this
country. I'm here today to share with
you that even though I'm afraid of what
will happen to me, I know that it takes
the courage of one person to change that
narrative. My whole life, Langster has
treated me and my family as part of its
community. And I've been thankful to
have been able to contribute and give
back to it. I hope as a community we can
choose to see one another with dignity
and create a place where the city truly
belongs to all of us.
Thank you.
[Applause]
Wow, that is
close. Hi everyone. Uh my name is Maya
McCully.
Um I am honored to be here uh to be part
of this amazing event that I never
thought would ever happen. Um, so I was
born and raised in Lancaster. Um, I am a
graduate of Macasy. Um, my family, we
came over in 1975 to um, Fort Indiantown
Gap.
And just thinking about it like even in
the in April because that was the 50-y
year anniversary of the
war. It's it's heavy because I imagine
my grandmother, my family, everyone just
leaving things behind, running towards
the water, trying to find a way out,
like running up a platform, trying to
grab onto a helicopter to find their way
out. And it's not lost on me that their
struggles and their journey to come here
has lifted me and put me in a place
where I can stand here in a room of
diversity and be able to talk to all of
you.
Um my family is so rooted in Lancaster.
Um the church on the corner St. James is
part of a network of churches that um
sponsored our family to come to America.
Uh my mother was the first Vietnamese
woman to graduate from Viet um from
Millersville University with a degree in
mathematics and I was blessed to be born
at St. Joseph um hospital right over
here and I still live here and raise my
two children here.
Um, I'm deeply honored to be able to
share my family story and to be part of
a community that opens doors and are now
holding open those doors. And sometimes
they are pushing open those doors for
families like mine to feel belong like
belonging to help them thrive and to
help them make it feel like home. Thank
you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much to each of you for
sharing your stories with us this
evening. Um I appreciate the part that
you play in AAPI history in Lancaster
and also the stories that are yet to be
told. Um we do have a motion and a
second on the floor for this resolution.
Uh are there any additional council
comments on the resolution? Councelor
Amed. Uh thank you council president. I
just want to thank the members of the
AAPI community who came out tonight and
also those who are not here. Um, and
just want to thank you for all that you
do for Langster City, um, as business
owners, community leaders, neighbors,
uh, and I encourage you to continue to
keep telling your stories because, um,
you know, we are better because of our
diversity and we are better because of
our welcoming and the, uh, AAPI
community here in Lancaster, uh, is a
model of how, uh, welcoming works and
how we are better, uh, because of our
new neighbors. Thank you.
Thank you, councelor Med. Additional
council comments.
Comments from the
public hearing. None. Mr. Harris. Mr.
Men. I. Mr. Roya. I. Mr. Cle. I. Miss.
Craig. I. Mr. Hirsh. I. President Baker.
I.
Folks, we do have a presentation copy of
this resolution and we'll uh grab a
photo. So, if everyone can bear with us
for just a moment while we do that.
Thank you everyone. Yes, I was going to
say uh do not need to stay for the whole
meeting, although you're invited to do
so if you wish. Uh we will move on to
our next item on the agenda. I believe
that is our first public comment period.
Again, this is reserved for residents
who contacted the city clerk prior to
the meeting to request the opportunity
to address council. Duration of comments
is limited to three minutes. And uh Mr.
Harris, do we have comments for the
first period this evening? Yes, we do,
Madam President. First is Amed Zaki.
Okay, Mr. Zaki.
Hello, city council and Mr. Mayor. I am
happy that I'm again here.
And my topic is opposite their
topic and I'm talking general. I I know
that you cannot you couldn't do
anything. Yeah, you cannot do anything
for
me. But just for a update, just for a
different way that I'm trying to explain
the
problems. Okay, a lot of you know that
my story know I don't need to repeat it.
Uh recently we took down our sign of our
restaurant after four years that city
council
condemned and it is very interesting and
shameful for a
country of law and
justice. Very easy. A person pay
inspector without uh pay inspector
running business without insurance and
proper
inspection. The
property, destroy our
business, sell our equipments, even not
pay our security
deposit. Challenge us at the court and
tell us that you cannot fight at the
court because you don't have money. We
have money.
you you cannot afford
it is right because the law and justice
is not in power. The money is in
power. This is not only our problem or
my problem. It's all our country
problem, society
problem. This is a big pro. There is a
big problem between rich and poor.
Justice systems in a state solve the
problem by not giving justice making it
is make it
expensive encouraging people and
encouraging everybody to get their right
by
themsel by commenting crime killing each
other or suicide themselves.
All you know the story of Liuji Liuji Mo
Morgan or Mayin
that insurance
story or there's a person in haunting
town killed himself in front of the
court and there's thousand story if you
go to the Google you can find a thousand
case about this killing murdering and
because of
unjustice who responsible for all this
suicide killing each child are
murdering and thousand case every day
every year happening. I I myself I blame
accuse the people on this business in
law business. Who is in law business?
Justice department, judges, lawyers or
any person who making money from the
blood of the people not from the solve
the problem. This all money they making
from the blood not from the solving the
problem.
And I'm I'm challenging all lawyers, all
judges. It is it is very first time that
I'm challenging. We've reached three
minutes. Okay. I I will continue next
time. Thank you.
Thank you. Appreciate it.
Mr. Harris, do we have any additional
commenters for this period? We do not,
Madam President. Thank you. Our next
item on the agenda this evening are
reports requested by council. Uh the
first one being interviews with
applicants for the Lancaster City Ethics
Commission. So I want to make a couple
of announcements before we jump into
those counselors. Tonight this is uh
first of two uh dates for interviews for
nominees to the ethics commission.
Although my intention was to have all
interviews completed at our June
committee meeting, there was some
conflict. So we will hold one interview
this evening. Remaining interviews will
take place at our June committee meeting
and then motions to nominate will be
heard at our June 10th regular meeting.
There will be a space on our agenda to
take nominations so that you are all
aware. Applicants are not required to be
at that June 10th meeting. Um just as a
refresher for everyone, applicants were
chosen for interviews by a ranked choice
voting system by which members of
council sent me their top two selections
from all nominees. And then uh my
intention was to take the top four.
There was a tie so there will be five
interviews. Um and then uh we are able
to appoint three members to this brand
new commission. Um so again this is
brand new and thank you everyone for
bearing with us as we sort of create a
process that doesn't already
exist. Uh this evening we have one
interview. Um it is I'm sorry I'm just
going to bring things up here to make
sure I have everything here. Uh we're
speaking with Theodore Griffith this
evening. Mr. Griffiths, you are here.
I'm gonna have you come forward and just
to give um everyone an update. I suspect
that these inter interview interviews
will be generally pretty brief, five
minutes uh to seven minutes tops. Uh
council also uh sent me some questions
that they might want to ask applicants.
I've compiled them in a list, sent them
to all members of council. They can
choose to use those questions if they
wish, but all members of council will be
given an opportunity to ask a question
of our applicants um after uh after we
begin. Um the first thing I want to do,
uh you have been asked these questions
before, Mr. Griffith. Good evening and
thank you for being here. Thank you for
having me. Sorry about um me being the
one conflict. I didn't realize that we
make it work. It's vacation time. I
understand. Um, you've been asked to
affirm these questions before, but I'm
just going to ask them again for our
meeting record. So, is your primary
residence within the city of Lancaster?
Yes. Okay. Um, have you held or uh any
appointed or elected office within city
government within the last year? No.
Thank you. Uh, have you held any
political party office within the last
year? No. Thank you. And have you held
any political action committee positions
within the last year? No, I have not.
Thank you very much. All right. So, I'm
going to begin by
um using my handydandy timer. Um if you
could provide us with an introduction
about a minute long, uh just a
background on uh who you are, any
relevant information we should know, and
why you wish to serve on this
commission. Thank you. Yes. So, um thank
you for having me again. Um I am
Theodore Griffiths. I'm a librarian and
I'm the manager of all the business
services and circulation at the
Lancaster Public Library right along the
way there. Uh, beyond all of my
librarian duties, I help local
entrepreneurs with all of our business
databases and I help them conduct market
research and then I link them up with
our community partners like Assets Score
and a few other financial institutions.
Uh, I also oversee our lovely front desk
staff. So, if you haven't been in the
new library, if it's been a while,
please stop in. Um, I'm a native of
Scranton, PA, but I've been in Lancaster
County since 2011. So, I went to
Millersville. I have a I have a
bachelor's
in I'm sorry. I have a bachelor's in
literature uh with a minor
in philosophy. Um extremely employable.
Um and then since then, yeah, once I
graduated, my wife and I ran a little
bed and breakfast for about four and a
half years. It's called the Hallinger
House. It's still going today, but in
2019, we decided we wanted to buy our
own home. So, we bought a house in the
southwest part of the city. and we
decided a couple years after that to go
back to school and get our master's
degrees. Uh I finished my master's
degree in library science just last year
and since then I have been given much
more responsibility at the library
itself. Um, I believe that my experience
on the library's internal policy
committee, uh, my handling of all of our
patrons, um, you know, you know, all
their private information, all their
reading habits, especially now that that
kind of stuff is kind of in the scope of
certain entities, plus my
dedication to the equity of access to
all kinds of information and my prior
experience as a manager of a business
form me into a candidate that can be
trusted to be nonpartisan, honest, and
observant. when constructing a city
ethics policy on this commission. Sorry,
I don't do public speaking. That's okay.
That's all right. Thank you very very
much. I'm actually gonna just go down
the line uh and allow counselors to ask
questions if they have them this
evening, beginning to my left this time
with councelor Hirs. Thank you, Council
President. Thank you, Theodore, for um
for stepping up into this role and
you're doing great on the public
speaking, so no worries. Um I just have
a question. um in regards to ethical
issues, you know, how do you see
yourself as um or how do you ensure that
your personal beliefs don't necessarily
uh conflict with fair and impartial
decision-m?
So, I think I understand that at the end
of the day, we we all have biases, but
um those do need to be kept at home. And
that's the same same thing at work as
well. So, for instance, I don't believe
in any like, you know, any form of
censorship. um as a librarian that is in
our entire code of ethics. It's it's you
know it's a founding principle of that.
But that means things that I disagree
with as well. There will be items in the
library that we keep in circulation
because freedom of information, freedom
to read whatever you want to read
regardless of what it is. And so I think
I can bring that into this role as well
as someone who um you know will
understand that while I may not agree
with something on a personal level,
there is good to it. It is ethical and I
bring that to my work as well. I think
that's important now more than ever.
Absolutely. Thank you, Theodore.
Councelor Craig,
thank you Council President and hello.
Good evening. It's very nice to see you
again. Could you tell us about a time
when you had an ethical dilemma and how
you solved it?
Yeah. So, um, let me think
here. I would say actually it came down
my previous job. I worked at another
library before this one. I was out at
Etown and um, we had a lot of books that
were propaganda, you might say
anti-trans.
um with dubious medical information in
them. Um but they were circulating. Some
of the patrons in that area were very
engaged with them.
And there was a part of me that wanted
to remove these books. There was a part
of me that said this this is not
scientifically backed. These aren't
peer- reviewviewed. But at the end of
the day, information and the freedom of
information is information. And those
books are still there to this day. I
don't work there anymore. I don't know
if we necessarily care anything like
that at LPL, but they're still there and
those people still have access to those
books even if I do not agree with them.
Fantastic. Thank you so much.
Go ahead and ask my question as we move
down the line. So, this is a volunteer
appointment um as the same with any of
our boards, commissions, authorities.
Have you served on any other volunteer
boards or commissions before? And if so,
what did you learn from that experience?
I actually have not. Um, I've been
working on my schooling the last few
years and before that we were running a
business. So, this is kind of the first
time I've had any of the free time, if
you will, to engage in something like
this. And I feel like this would be a
great place to do it because I love this
community. I love this city. I love the
Southwest where I live. And uh, yeah, I
just think it would be Yeah. nice. I
think now's the time. I appreciate that.
And I appreciate you saying that you
have the time uh to commit because
that's also very important in these
volunteer roles. Yeah. So, thank you.
Thanks, Councelor Klester.
Thank you, M. Thank you, Madame
President, and thank you for your
willingness to serve. And uh how would
you ensure that the commission's
decisions are applied fairly and
consistently under the home charter
regardless of the position, status, or
political connections of the individuals
involved? So, I think that's where the
entire commission comes in. I'm hoping
uh like any good commission that there
are people from multiple different
backgrounds, a very diverse commission
um of all different ages as well. Um so
then when we're looking at you know any
policy
um we can engage with that from a lot of
different perspectives and I feel like
that is how you make sure that something
is fair for all is that all different
eyes have to be on it. I would just be
one. I'm a 35-year-old white guy, but
I'm hoping that the entire committee is
made up of a lot of different people so
that we can have multiple sets of eyes
on there to make sure that these
decisions, that these policies are fully
ethical. Good. Thank you,
Counc. Thank you, Council President.
Thank you, Theodore, for uh your
willingness to serve. Um how would you
handle a situation where someone you
know is subject to an ethics complaint?
Well, um, in that case, in a situation
like this,
I I have my friends, I have my family,
but at the end of the day, I I was
raised by a Marine, and it's all about
the good of the entire community. It's
about, you know, it's about the good of
your entire platoon. And unfortunately,
sometimes that means that you have to
turn your back on people that are making
bad decisions, and you have to push
forward. And, um, you can't stick by
them. Um, you can't let that slide.
uh you have to face that head on and
acknowledge that this person that I care
about, this person I like has made a bad
decision and I have to call that out and
I would absolutely do that.
Thank you, Council President, and thank
you, Theodore, for your uh willingness
to serve and answering our questions
this evening. How do you believe that
integrity and honesty and elected
officials can build trust in the
community? I mean, I think it's
everything. Um, I I think if you see,
you know, the people that you voted for,
if you see them engaging in things that
are that are dishonest, um, if you see
them kind of not standing up for the
little guy sometimes, not that I'm
saying anyone's doing that, by the way,
that is not a um, but I feel like it's,
you know, it's all about that trust.
It's all about seeing them walk the
walk, seeing them everything they say on
the campaign trail, they do in their
office as well. Um, and it's the same
thing, you know, for someone like me who
would not, I'm not a politician. I would
not be, you know, in an elected office,
but to make sure that even when I'm out
in public, when I'm out around the city,
that I am engaging in, you know, fair
behavior and, you know, I'm being a good
custodian of this city. And I feel like
that's extremely important. Thank you.
Yeah. Thank you very much, councelor
Amed. Any last pressing questions for
members of council?
Mr. Griffith, thank you so much for
being here this evening. Again, we will
uh convene the rest of our interviews at
our next committee meeting in June and
then motions will be taken at our June
10th meeting. I sincerely appreciate you
taking the time to be here this evening.
Yep. Thank you very much.
[Applause]
Our next item on the agenda is still
under reports requested by council. uh
council, we will hear tonight uh an
update for the office of healthy homes.
So, we'll let them get set up
here. And so, I believe your present do
you have a a presentation or just a We
do. We do have a presentation like a
visual presentation. Yes, we do. Okay.
Just note that I don't think that
counselors are able to see it at this
time. So, if we could get your slides,
it'll be on the screen behind us. So,
folks folks here will have it, but uh AV
issues being what they are, we won't
have it in front of us at the
moment, but if you're able to send it to
Mr. Harris, uh he can forward it to us
so we can pull it up. Absolutely. Okay,
let's do
that. That's a good idea.
That's a note for any city staff right
now until we get this taken care of, but
please do that.
Yes,
you have it. Yeah. And uh President By,
would you like uh Mr. Harris to share
that with you right now so you can look
at it or just That would be helpful if
we're able to do that. If that's not We
can take a moment to get that together.
quite a bit.
All right.
Is it? No, that's not it.
Is it beaming to us through the Wi-Fi?
Okay, counselors, you should have it in
your inboxes. Thank you for bearing with
us while we got
that. Oh, it is saying we need
permission to access that link.
Does anyone have a hard copy that they
could simply forward to members of
council?
Let's let's print it. Can we print it
from here? Thank you.
Or even if you have a file and not a
SharePoint link that we could access
or a PDF or something like that.
Just to be clear, is that coming our way
via email
or what is the the plan?
Okay.
Okay, got
it. So, am I the only one who's able to
bring it up or can I forward this now to
everyone or I
because I can't download from this file
and try to share it with everybody.
Does it exist in a PDF format? No. Okay.
We're sending it to each and everyone.
Great. Thank you.
It does seem like the PDF version has
now been shared into all of our
inboxes. Yes. Can I get confirmation
from another Okay. Yes. Okay. Great. All
right. Okay.
you
can. Thank you so
much. Thank you all for your patience.
We discussed this and I said that the
technology will be
fine. Should have known.
Try again. Okay, game on.
We do lead remediation and healthy homes
programming way better than we do
technology.
So I'm here presenting this evening.
Good evening with good evening
counselors and mayor uh Rebecca Geyser,
deputy director in community planning
and economic development for those in
the audience who don't know me. and I'm
here presenting with Alen Lapesh and
Daniel Sosa from the Office of Healthy
Homes and we'll be sharing this
presentation and we are so excited to
share with you tonight the impactful
work led by the Office of Healthy Homes
over uh the mayor's term. We've
significantly expanded these programs
and we want to share with you what we've
been able to accomplish over the last
several years and also what we hope to
accomplish in the coming years.
For reference, uh this is CPED's
organizational chart, slide two, and the
office of healthy homes is situated
within the health bureau under the
leadership of Craig Walt. Unfortunately,
uh Craig is ill this evening and is
unable to be with us. Um but I I he
would have had the copies for you
all and he's prepared the team for this
presentation. For many years, we've le
we've referred to this team as the lead
team. Everyone calls this the lead team.
Um but we have rebranded ourselves um
and rebranded the programs as the office
of healthy homes really to highlight our
broad focus on various programs to
promote health, safety and well-being of
which remediation is now just one part
of all the office of healthy homes
programming which uh as you'll
see to the next slide. This is a photo
of our team and the office of healthy
homes is made up of these five
individuals uh when and two others when
fully staffed. Uh and all team members
started with the city in 2021 or later.
So it's really remarkable to see the
team building and capacity building that
you'll hear about this evening that has
opened up the programming uh over the
last several years. Alise Pi out the who
is the community development program
administrator. you've seen her before
present. She also supports these efforts
through overseeing our grant management
and our
compliance. So, in line with the health
bureau's mission to promote and protect
the health and well-being of Lancaster
City, the Office of Healthy Homes
mission is to promote safe and healthy
living environments through an array of
programs and services. We aim to achieve
uh these interrelated goals related to
health and housing. And you can see the
first three, reducing health and safety
hazards, prevent childhoodled poisoning,
and stabilizing homes and neighborhoods
are very obvious goals and connections.
But in addition, this program also
impacts important economic development
goals within the city to preserve
affordable housing and sustain home
ownership and supporting local
contractors and small businesses. As we
do the
work, the most effective public health
programs address a magnitude of issues
and are a part of a strategic and
comprehensive approach to make long
lasting impact on our community. And
this team is truly knocking it out of
the park. And I'm so glad to be a part
of the presentation this evening to
provide you with some of the details
about their work and the lives that
they've impacted.
Hi, I'm Elaine Lapesh and programs
manager for the team and I'm I'm very
happy to be with you tonight and be able
to share our programming and some of the
things some of the goals that we've
reached over the last several years and
what we have to look forward
to. If we can leave one thing with you
tonight, it's that we have three
programs in our office of healthy homes.
So lead is very important and we don't
mind being called the lead team, but
we're more than that and we want to make
sure that people in the city are aware
of it. So I'm going to go over our three
programs and then Daniel will expand a
little bit more upon it. Uh the lead
hazard control program is probably the
one you're most familiar with. Uh we
received a $9.7 million grant in um 2019
and are just wrapping up that grant now.
Um but in this program we perform a
surface by surface lead inspection and
risk assessment in a house and then
develop a scope of work that directly
addresses each of the lead hazards. So
to be a lead hazard, it's lead positive
and it's also deteriorated.
The critical repair program is a program
just for homeowners living in Langster
City and we address one or sometimes two
very big issues and these are critical
or emergency issues that may cause the
owner to have to leave their home. Um,
I'm very proud of this program because
often we have longtime homeowners that
there's just been deferred maintenance
or a sewer pipe collapses, just one big
issue um, that's very expensive and hard
to save for, hard to plan for, and we
can help them out. Um, we screen issues
for this one over the phone, so we don't
require that they submit an application
before we review the emergency repair
that they have. That way they're not
wasting their time. If they filled out
an application, knew they were eligible,
and then we went and looked and said,
"Well, you know, we we don't use this
program for a leaking faucet," then they
would have wasted all that
time. The healthy homes program, um, we
received part of the money from the lead
hazard control program, um, for healthy
homes. So, it was a $9.7 million grant.
The 700,000 was for healthy homes
issues. So when we were in a house doing
the lead work, we would also be able to
fix some of the other um healthy homes
issues that were not lead
based. Um part of the healthy home stuff
too is we are able to flag some of the
urgent issues that we would otherwise
address through critical repair. So
that's been um a good way to help us
find funding for people.
Great. So throughout the presentation,
we're going to be um zooming in then uh
zooming out and zooming back in again.
Uh so with that, I wanted to dive in a
little bit more into the programs that
we have uh at the city in our in our
office. So, with the lead hazard control
program, uh that can look like a lot of
different things, but it may include new
windows, new doors, new porch floors, uh
new flooring on the stairs, uh freshly
painted and stabilized trim, um and new
trim, uh enclosing porch ceilings with
vinyl or other exterior components, uh
or new sod, mulch or turf, um on the uh
play areas on the outside of the house.
Um the the lead hazard control scope of
work is determined based on an
inspection that our um housing rehab and
lead specialist and uh our risk assessor
when we do hire one um there it's based
on their inspection and the lead hazard
control program has been funded through
the large um housing and urban
development grant that was previously
mentioned and also through uh a grant
that we got through the uh Pennsylvania
Department of Health.
And then we have the critical repair
program. As mentioned, uh these are big
issues that that might affect a house.
Um those could be leaking roofs, broken
furnaces or water heaters, fractured
sewer pipes, structural problems that
could danger um the house of collapsing,
electrical issues that could start a
fire. Um this program has been funded
over the years by community development
block grants and through the American
Rescue Plan Act. Um, we also work with
um a loan program that's uh offered out
of Tenfold as well um to help folks that
might be over our um our income
guidelines that we
have. And then we have the healthy homes
program. Uh and these can include some
of those critical issues that that we
mentioned earlier. Uh but there's a big
focus in the healthy homes program on
radon testing and mitigation, smoke and
carbon uh monoxide detectors and fire
extinguishers. accessibility through
handrails and ramps. Um pest management,
weatherization,
uh moisture issues and other asthma
triggers also are addressed through the
healthy homes program. And this has been
funded through housing urban development
as well and will be uh going
forward. And so then we have uh some
elig eligibility requirements that go
with all of our programs. The income
guidelines are the same for all of our
programs that we have. It is 80% of the
area median income, which uh visually
speaking is is the chart um attached to
this slide. Um the um that is the the
current income uh qualifications, but we
also do have a uh a partnership with the
Lancaster City Housing Authority for
folks that are receiving housing
vouchers, commonly known as section 8.
um where income eligibility is is
streamlined for those folks. We've been
able to do um I believe at least 50 um
of the scattered sites throughout the
city uh with this partnership. Um
another eligibility requirement is that
the deed property owner must apply uh
for the for the project. Seemed pretty
obvious, but um the property must have
property insurance. Um and the property
must be used as a primary residence. Um
those that's another eligibility
requirement. And then a small co um
niche requirement for the lead hazard
control program is that it has to be
built before 1978, which as you guys all
know is the great majority of the houses
um in Lancaster City.
there is a there is quite the
documentation uh that goes along with
becoming eligible for the program that
you have to provide. Um it can be
burdensome for some folks, but we've put
a lot of work um over the last few years
to actually reduce the amount of
paperwork and provide support for folks
that are applying to make it um less of
a burden on on their time. Um and uh
we've seen a lot of success through that
as well.
Um, in the next couple of slides,
Rebecca's going to be able to brag for
us about our productivity over the last
year, especially. Um, but I want to talk
a little bit about how we got there, how
we were able to manage that, and what
are the key things um that we've done or
um that have come along that have been
able to um increase our
productivity. Um, outreach and
referrals. Uh, I really can't say enough
about some of the partnerships that
we've developed, especially with the PA
Department of Health. Um, Craig, I'm
sorry he can't be here tonight because
he's very proud of some of the
improvements that we've made. And one of
the things he worked very hard at was to
get a data sharing agreement with the
Department of Health so that um, lead
poison kids would be reported to us, not
for enforcement, but so that we could
offer our program to their families. Um,
and that's been that's been really
wonderful. Um, also, um, as Dan
mentioned, the section 8 partnership
that we have with the housing authority,
that has really paved the way for a lot
of landlords that accept section 8
vouchers um, to put their their um,
properties through our program without
burdening their tenants with a lot of
the paperwork. So, they still have to
fill out an application, but then it's
automatic eligibility uh, because of the
section 8 voucher. Um the lead ordinance
that that we expanded last year has also
made a huge difference in our program.
So it's really attracted the attention
of a lot of landlords. And um and
fortunately once they put one property
through our program, they're eager to
get other properties enrolled as well.
And we kind of expect this to explode a
little bit next year when we go
citywide, which we'll talk about with
our next
grant enrollment. Um, one thing that has
made, like Dan mentioned as well, one
thing that has made a huge difference is
the attention that we pay to each
application a couple years ago, Dan and
I kind of put our heads together about
our enrollment numbers and then amount
of applications that we were receiving
and figured out that only about 35% of
the applications were actually getting
over the finish line. So, we've worked
very hard to once we engage with someone
to really really stay on it until, you
know, if if they say absolutely, we're
done. We don't want to continue, that's
fine. But we will do whatever we can to
help their application be approved. And
also, language access, we've gotten much
better at that. We have a really good
software app on our phones called Propio
that we're able to do three-way live um
interpretation and in any language. and
it's been amazing. And I have to shout
out to Nat Swanson. She's our outreach
and education specialist. She is really
passionate about language access and
language justice and she has been
amazing with helping people finish these
applications. So, we do need the
application in English. HUD requires
that, but she can go through the entire
thing with them in whatever language
they prefer um and help them fill it
out.
And then also project workflow. Um we we
just keep looking for ways every day
we're looking for ways to improve our
workflow. Um our risk assessor right now
we only have Forest, the tall guy in the
picture. He's our only rehab specialist
right now. Um and he has to do a lot of
paperwork. So we're always looking for
ways to support him. Um eliminate
paperwork where we can. We do a lot of
Adobe sign which we didn't used to do.
We used to be running around getting
signatures all the time. We do a lot
more things electronically. We got new
XRF guns that work faster and are easier
to manage. Um, and we
also try to help landlords not to have
to duplicate the information they give
to us. So, if they're enrolling 10
properties, we're only collecting their
ID one time. We're only getting their um
operating agreement one time. We're only
getting their property management
agreement one time. Um, and that really
helps them
out. So, I'll let Rebecca talk about our
numbers. This slide speaks for itself.
If you're not there yet, um, you can
move to the bar
graph. These are the outcomes and inc
impacts of the incredible growth in the
capacity of this team since 2020. the
amount of money and the amount of
projects we have completed. Um you you
can't um maybe see in the red, maybe you
can probably better on your computers,
but for for the um people in the house
here, we
completed 170 lead hazard control
projects this year alone and 40 critical
repair projects uh utilizing the
designated ARPA allocation um awarded by
city council. So, this really made um a
very large impact in the community and
our ability to carry out these critical
repair projects. Um, and I especially
want to highlight, as Elaine mentioned,
the commitment to equitably offering
services to all of Lancaster through
their streamlining of those um referrals
and um application processes. And
um so in 2024, you can see we've doubled
the amount that we spent on lead
remediation leading up to the last
months of this high impact grant. We are
closing that out here at the end of May
and have successfully spent down that
grant um all of the money that was
allocated for lead remediation. And that
is uh quite an accomplishment on the
part of the team and uh and the
community development team to to bring
that to
fruition. So just to recap a little bit
with our lead hazard control grant uh we
completed 403 lead remediation projects
in total. Uh we those were all in
targeted five census tracks in the
southern quadrants. Um I wanted to add a
little bit about our average lead
project cost. Um so we ended up with an
average of 175 which is much higher than
we had anticipated when we wrote our
grant application. So um in ju June or
July of 2023 we had a HUD audit visit
where our representatives really
encouraged us to do more abatement uh
for our projects. So couple technical
terms abatement means to permanently
remove lead um whereas interim control
is something that will require
maintenance in the future. So we were
doing a lot of inter room control, a lot
of scrape and paint on trim and they
said, "Hey, whenever you can get it out
of there." So there's this fine balance
because we are working in some beautiful
old homes. So sometimes we don't want to
remove the trim and replace it. But when
it's really beat up and has seen better
days, has 10 coats of paint on, we're
doing a lot more of remove and replace
um than we used to. So that has driven
up our project cost. Um it did mean that
we had to lower our target numbers uh
the number of houses that we could
serve. Um but like Rebecca said, we
ended up spending all the funds that we
had um for lead abatement. Um and we're
really happy about that. And I also want
to point out that we require landlords
to cover 10% of the costs. Um so that
has resulted in nearly a half a million
dollars of private funds being put into
the housing stock of Lancaster City. as
well. Uh the Pennsylvania Department of
Health grant, we were able to do 34
properties um through them and actually
we signed a couple more contracts this
week. So that number has gone up. They
have allowed us to go citywide, not just
in the target area. So when we get a
case that it's a household with lead
poisoning, we're able to help them even
though they're not in the target area
that we had for HUD.
uh critical repair, like Rebecca
mentioned, we were able to do 40
projects, um which is almost double
anything we've ever done before in a
year.
Um the vast majority are roofs. Um I I
like to say I don't know that anybody
likes to hear this, but even though
people worry about lead, it's really
those leaking roofs and collapsed sewer
pipes that keep people up at night that
really give them anxiety about their
house. And sometimes it gets ignored and
sometimes there's a lot of rot um that
goes along with it. But those are high
dollar items and it's hard for any of us
to save up $30,000 and be ready for that
bill, right? Um I say $30,000. We don't
go that high, but some roofs we have
gone up to I think 21,000. No, 25,000
has been the highest for a roof. And
we'll actually see a picture of that in
a minute. There's a Cedar Shake house in
um the Harb District.
healthy homes. Again, this uh the
healthy homes grant that we're talking
about from 2020 to 2024 was only for
houses where we'd also done lead work.
So, the average cost per house stayed
relatively low, um about 5,500 and we
did 106 homes with healthy homes
supplemental funds. So, we'll talk about
moving forward. We have a new grant
called healthy homes production that we
can use as a standalone. it doesn't have
to be used alongside alongside lead. Um
so that will allow us to do even
more. And now we have a a few pictures
um Dan's going to talk
about. I'll go through these relatively
relatively fast, but these are just a
few examples of some of the projects
that we've done over the past few years.
Um this was a porch that was uh
replaced. It was all lead painted porch
that got replaced with with new with new
decking, not new paint, but brand new
decking in in total. Um, a big thing
that we do with window replacement um is
because the windows are a big friction
uh point. So, anytime you open or close
a window creates dust and and paint
chips that become a major hazard. So,
replacing them can go a really long way
towards making a home led safe. Um, with
the healthy homes program, we do a lot
of the smoke detectors, fire
extinguishers, radar mitigation. I bet a
lot of you guys have these in your
homes. And then plumbing or
accessibility issues. This is a before
and after of a bathroom that we
fixed. This is that big roof that uh
Elaine mentioned. You could see through
it. You can, you know, you can see
daylight out out of it, but it got
replaced with a brand new um brand new
roof. Really great stuff. And then
another major concern for folks is
heating issues. Uh you know your heating
source is broken during the winter.
Replacing that can be lifech changer,
lifesaver literally. So yeah, another
example of
that and then we're going to look ahead.
We are so pleased to report that
although the high impact grant that
you've heard so much about is coming to
a close this month, uh we have secured
an addition an additional $7 million in
lead hazard control coming up and
anticipate completing 300 additional
projects with that money. We do have
about $100,000 in ARPA remaining for
critical repair and $2.75 million in
healthy homes which is uh we expect to
complete about 180 projects. So we are
very excited to continue the
sustainability of this program and I we
really appreciate that you all have
listened to our presentation. And our
final important message to residents and
to all of you is uh everyone deserves a
safe and healthy home. So if you have
need of any of these programs or know of
residents, please refer them to us. I
believe we have given you brochures.
There are some on the table there for
people in the room and we are very glad
to receive your referrals and thank you
for all of your support uh through ARPA,
through CDBG and um through your
referrals to our program over the years.
We're we're just so glad to be
partnering with you on this program.
Thank you very much uh to all of you for
all of your amazing work. Um
yes, a huge round of applause to you and
your entire team and and tell Craig,
thank you as well. U I just wanted to
say that I remember I was just coming on
to council when the grant came to us in
2019. I remember us, if I remember
correctly, we all including the
counselors elect at that time signed our
names on the big check that we got. Um,
and it was it was really amazing and to
think about the possibility that was a
part of that and now to be at the
conclusion of that and know that we have
uh more uh we can move forward because
we've proven that we can do it um is a
testament to everybody on the team and
everybody who put it into action. So,
thank you so much for that. Really
appreciate it. Any additional comments
from council on the report that we
received? Council Royo?
Thank you, Council President. Uh, just
wanted to say thank you to the team. Um,
out of the many departments and programs
in our city, this is definitely one of
the one or these three programs are one
of the ones I brag about a lot to our
residents. And it's really cool to see
the completed number of projects over
the years. And want to give a shout out
to Dan because I know personally that
you went out and knocked doors to get
the word out um about the specifically
the lead uh program. But um it's really
cool to see how much impact we've had in
our city over the years. So, thank you
so much to the team for making it
happen.
Councelor Craig, yeah, I just want to
say piggyback on what councelor Royal
has said and just to say thank you,
Council Hersh. Thanks for all you do.
Um, and I just the only thing I wanted
to add is I loved um the innovative uh
partnerships that were seen particularly
with the city housing authority. I just
thought that was brilliant and the ways
you guys did that to get more out of it.
I thought that was really excellent. So,
thank you,
Mayor Saraji. Uh, thank thank you. I
just want to um when we received the
award in 2019, we were one of the high
impact HUD um recipients, which made us
one of a handful uh on par with Detroit
and Baltimore, the state of Rhode Island
and Houston. And I I don't mean to put
you on the spot, but I think we're
leading the nation. Um, and so can you
just talk a little bit about that
because I think we have bragging
rights. Thank you, mayor. And I just
appreciate so much your support and how
much you've talked us up because it has
helped um in a lot of different um in a
lot of different areas. and the
resources that we've received. Um we are
one of the top performing. We actually
um you know as I mentioned we decreased
our production numbers to to 400 because
we had increased the price per property
and most of the other high impact grants
grantees had not even proposed that high
of a number. Um they were more in the
300 to 350 range. So I'm not sure where
they're all ending up. we'll have um I
think we'll have access to those results
as they close out their grants too. Um
but definitely we have heard from HUD
that we're one of the top performers and
that's always great to hear. Um but it
also positioned us well for the
follow-up grants that we received
including the healthy homes production
grant. Um we ran out of our healthy
homes supplemental funds for that first
grant about two years before the end of
the lead grant. So, if we hadn't
received that Healthy Homes production
grant, we kind of would have had a
little more of a hole in our services.
So, having our reputation for production
really helped us there. Thank you and
congratulations again.
Thank you so much. All right. Uh that
will take us to our next item on the
agenda, which is interimm reports of
committees of council, of which we do
not appear to have any more of
those. Mr. Harris, just let me know when
you're set to from a technical
standpoint. Are you good over there to
proceed? Okay. Oh, we need the
dongle. We're working on a dongle system
now.
Okay, thank you. So, that will take us
into our legislative agenda this
evening. The first item is ordinances
for final passage. For that, we begin
with administration bill number 4, 2025.
Mr. Harris, if you would please. Yes,
Madam President. an ordinance of the
Lancaster City Council amending chapter
155 historic districts of the code of
the city of Lancaster by revising the
definition of building official and
clarifying a big a building official's
membership on the city city of Lancaster
historical architectural review board
and historical commission providing for
the appointment of a building official
or officials to the historical
architectural review board andor
commission by the director of the
department of community and economic
development, providing for the repeal of
inconsistent ordinances, providing for
the separability of the ordinance, and
providing that the ordinance shall take
effect in accordance with Pennsylvania
law. Motion to approve. Second. We have
a motion and a second. This was coming
up through community planning committee.
Councelor Craig. Thank you, Council
President. Um, if I'm not mistaken, I
think dire I believe director Del um
presented this to us in committee. Um
the bill bill bill four this amendment
will update the definition of the
building
officials within the definition of
building officials within the historic
historic district ordinance. This is the
to create a more
flexible to create more flexible for
appointments to the historical
architectural review board and
historical commission. The current
ordinance refers to the building
officials that dates back to when the
city only had
one. Now there are
several. The ordinance would also
delegate to the director of community
planning and economic development the
authority to to designate the building
officials to serve on those boards.
Thank you very much, Councelor Craig.
Dr. Delves, good evening. Do you have
anything in addition to add? I know
we've reviewed this at committee and at
our previous meeting. Uh good evening,
city council, mayor, members of the
public. Um uh thank you, councelor
Craig. I I think that was an excellent
summary. I I really don't have very much
uh to add. I know as a uh bill, this is
the second reading before council. Uh we
also addressed it in committee. So I I
believe we have talked about the
fundamentals of the bill. Um, as you
said, really at the heart of this um,
ordinance change is uh, a a a desire to
update the building official definition
um, and to align that with the modern
um, professional certification standards
for commercial code inspectors that we
have on staff. Um the the current
ordinance does already require that both
the historical commission and the harb
uh have a building official as one of
the members on the commission uh and the
board. Uh so this is just u making a
small amendment uh in order to build in
some of that flexibility that you
described.
Great. Thank you so much counselors. Any
council comments on the
bill from the public
hearing? None. Mr. Harris. Mr. Matt. I.
Mr. Roya. I. Mr. Cle. I. Mr. Craig. I.
Mr. Hirs. I. President Baker. I. Thank
you. Our next item on the legislative
agenda is item B. These are resolutions.
Uh we have tonight administration
resolution number
362025. Mr. Harris, a resolution of the
council of the city of Lancaster
approving the adoption of an amendment
to the act 537 official sewage
facilities plan for the city of
Lancaster.
Motion to approve. Second. We have a
motion and a second. This is also coming
up through community planning. Councelor
Craig. Thank you, Council President. We
we've done these several times before.
The Pennsylvania Department of
Environmental Protection requires that
the municipality do to adopt an official
sewage facilities plan providing for the
services adequate to prevent
contamination and environmental health
hazards with sewer waste and amend from
time to time when necessary to asssure
there is adequate sewage disposal.
Um the owners at&m Global LLC
have proposed the development of parcel
land at 617 Fremont Street. The city has
of Lancaster has found that the project
described planning module conforms to
applicable sewage related zoning and
other sewage uh related municip
municipal ordinances and plans.
So, thank you very much. Hello. Hello.
If you have any questions regarding the
sewage module, I can um provide. Sure.
I appre I know we've done a bunch of
these and just for purposes of anyone
listening wondering what uh we're
speaking about this uh certifies that
this project there's adequate sewage
capacity to proceed with this project
and it is the first of uh many uh sort
of applications and permit processes
that may happen for this project. So
it's it is it is before any other
planning has happened. Is that correct?
Um that's correct. This one actually you
guys approved back in March, but because
um of a timing issue with county
planning approval, it's actually back
before you to kind of certify that
approval. That's right. This address did
seem familiar. Thank you for reminding
us of that. Any additional council
comments on the
resolution from the
public?
Hearing none. Mr. Harris. Mr. Man. I.
Mr. Roya. I. Mr. Cle. I. Miss. Craig. I.
Mr. Hirs. I. President Baker. I. Thank
you. Our next item under resolutions is
administration resolution number
392025. Mr. Harris. A resolution of the
council of the city of Lancaster
approving World Refugee Day flag raising
on January 20th, 2025 to celebrate the
refugee experience and acknowledge the
contributions of refugees to Lancaster
as brought forth by councelor Med.
Motion to approve. Second. We have a
motion and a second. Councelor Med,
anything to add for this one? Uh, this
was your request. Um, not much to add.
Uh just want to thank uh the
administration uh for their commitment
to continuing to recognize World Refugee
Day here in Lancaster. Um and this uh
World Refugee Day, we'll be doing a flag
raising where we will be flying the uh
refugee nation flag uh which is um a
symbolic flag for refugees across the
world. Um it is an orange flag with a
black stripe uh down the bottom to
symbolize the horizon uh that refugees
um have to find um in their um long
quest. Um but it also symbolizes life
jackets that many refugees may have had
to use um uh during their travels. We
look forward to the flag raising on June
20th to continue to honor the
contributions, experience, and stories
of our refugee neighbors here in
Lancaster. Thank you very much,
Councelor Med. Um, and as this pertains
to the next this item and the next item
on our agenda, I'll also remind council
that the process um for submitting
requests to raise a flag um happens
through our department of neighborhood
engagement and uh individuals or
organizations that wish to request uh
can do so online uh in advance which I
believe is 120 days I believe is the the
threshold. So that is available to you.
Any additional council comments on the
resolution?
Council Royal. Oh, councelor. Thank you,
council president. Um, councelor Med,
uh, the time of the flag raising,
uh, I believe it is 10:00 a.m. I would
have to get back to uh, you the the
exact time of the flag raising. Yeah,
the resolution doesn't specify a time,
only a date. So, thank you for letting
us know. Yeah.
Additional council
comments from the public.
Hearing none. Mr. Harris, Mr. Med I, Mr.
Royal, I. Mr. Cle, I, Miss Craig, I, Mr.
Hirs, I, and President Baker,
I. And finally, resolution number 40,
2025. Mr. Harris, when you're ready.
Sorry.
A resolution of the council of the city
of Lancaster approving the Junth flag
raising on June 19th, 20125 to
acknowledge the emancipation of
African-Americans brought forth by the
National Association for the Advancement
of Colored People. Motion to approve.
Second. A motion and a second.
Councilors, thank you for hearing this
one. You might recall that shortly after
Junth of 2024, we actually approved a
flag raising um for 2025. Um the request
has been uh submitted to change the
date. And so this is a bit of a
housekeeping resolution uh to ensure
that we have everything recorded
properly. Uh the flag raising date will
be changed to actually occur on June
19th, 2025. Again, we have previously
approved this request and this is just
amending the date. Any additional
council comments on this
one from the
public hearing? None. Mr. Harris. Mr.
Madden. I. Mr. Royo. I. Mr. Cle. I.
Miss. Greg. I. Mr. Hirs. I. And
President Be
I. Right. That will conclude our
legislative agenda this evening. The
next item in front of us is our second
public comment period. Again, this is
open uh for items not previously heard
on the agenda. Duration of comments is
limited to three minutes per speaker. If
there's anyone wishing to participate in
this public comment period, please come
forward at this
time. Please come on
up. Mr. Zaki, good evening. And I I
believe I missed I made a note. U if you
could just begin with your name and
block of residence for a record. Thank
you. My name is Ahmed Zaki and live in
336 Beaver
Street and I'm trying sorry that I'm
trying to continue again what I
left. Uh I will be the first person that
I am calling the lawful people as a
criminal because I'm thinking they by
not giving the justice to people they
committing crime. They encouraging
people to go kill somebody or to suicide
himself. And I'm challenging all lawyers
and judge if can prove it or
not.
And the some people trying to bring
peace in Ukraine and Gaza here. I think
they should bring peace in here because
there's a conflict between rich and
poor
and prevent from the crime
from they creating the crime but they if
they bring peace that they can do some
saying the American first yeah this is
the time that American first bring peace
in here a real peace in the heart in the
community not not by forcing put give a
person a a life sentence in the jail.
That's not the peace like the death they
give for the that person
Luigi.
Uh as a update we filed our case in the
court.
Uh I I I took my kids money from tax
return money to file my my case in
court and it need a lot of money to
process this case. I don't know how I
will be able to comp to to collect that
money to pay for the lawyers or for the
court or not.
And I hope
that I hope that this problem will solve
but
not harm myself like the other person
did in front of the
court because
uh I love my
kids. I'm not commenting a crime if I
was doing I was I was not
here. But uh I hope that everything will
go well.
And uh this is all my work. Thank you so
much. Thank you very much, Mr.
Zaki. Any additional uh commenters for
the second public comment
period. Hearing none, I will close
public comment and we will move uh to
our next item on the agenda this
evening. Uh that would be the report of
the mayor, Mayor Srachi. Thank Thank
you, Council President. Uh tonight I'd
like to take a moment to recognize the
school district of Lancaster and its
incredible students. Uh over the years
uh SDOL and the city have built a strong
and meaningful partnership and I want to
recognize a few pieces of uh SDL news.
So first uh I want to congratulate
Macasy's unified track and field and
varsity track and field athletes
athletes who competed at the
PIAA state championships at Shippensburg
this past weekend. varsity track and
field team placed second. A remarkable
achievement and all the student athletes
make our entire city proud. And the only
reason why I had awareness of this is
that last week I and several city staff
had the pleasure of judging the school
district of Lancaster STEM fair. And it
was as I was leaving the STEM fair that
there was the drum line and all the
cheerleaders as they were sending off um
the athletes uh onto the bus to head to
Shippensburg. And it was just such a
wonderful moment of school spirit and
community pride. So I just want to um
recognize that. And then as it relates
to the STEM fair, uh several of us had
the chance to go and judge um projects
and I think as well uh councelor Aoyo um
uh Molly, our deputy director of public
works for sustainability, Rebecca, who
you heard from tonight, um and Betsy
also who you heard from tonight, um got
to uh witness the passion and innovation
of these young minds at the STEM fair
and their projects were pretty amazing
and they They have recently uh taken on
a number of projects that are directly
related to the city, whether that's
around storm water or litter.
Um and uh I just I highly recommend if
council members ever get asked to go to
absolutely do it because you will be
shocked uh at what these kids are coming
up with. Uh I also, you know, one of the
key programs connecting the city and the
school district has been the JP McCasky
Neighborhood Leaders Academy, which has
been an outstanding program over the
years with 84 students compete
completing it since its inception. At
our last meeting, we saw this um and the
program continues to shape future
leaders and strengthen the ties between
Macasy and our city government. And just
this morning, I attended the Witness
Stones Project ceremony um and saw the
hard work of Macasky social studies
students who researched the stories of
four enslaved residents of Lancaster.
They spoke eloquently at the ceremony
about the research that they did and
what they learned about these four
individuals. One, two of them were
children and it was really clear that
they were passionate about the project.
And finally, this week is Macasky's
graduation. Uh it will be held on
Thursday night. Uh an annual highlight
for sure. Um I have the opportunity to
speak at the ceremony and to celebrate
their perseverance and dedication and um
this one this last one will certainly be
extra special for me uh to celebrate the
class of 2025.
So, I'm really deeply proud of how our
city employees have embraced
collaboration with the school district
on key initiatives like bike and
pedestrian safety, youth engagement,
public safety, and community building.
There is uh much more to collaborate on
and I'm grateful both to our city
departments and school district of
Lancaster staff who are really eager to
keep that partnership going strong.
Thank you, council. Thank you very much,
Mayor Sarra. Uh our next item is the
report of president of council. I don't
have a specific report, but I wanted to
thank you for highlighting the work uh
that our students are doing. It is truly
incredible when I get a chance to
interact with them, whether they come
through um city hall uh as part of the
neighborhood leaders academy or we're
going out into classrooms to talk to,
you know, social studies class. Um I'm
always amazed at the the questions and
the thoughtful questions that they ask
of us and how engaged and interested
they are in learning about how they can
interact with their local government.
So, thank you. Um, the next item on the
agenda is council comments. Are there
any comments from council tonight?
Council president, if I may, councelor.
I just wanted to make the other members
of council aware that the home rule
study transition committee did meet on
May 6th and went over both the
administrative code um as well as the
ethics uh code uh which will be um uh
which we are currently doing the
interviews for and uh will be more to
come. But we are on track and we are on
time. And that concludes my report.
Thank you very much, Councelor Med. I
will also just to backtrack a little bit
because you mentioned that I will
mention to members of council that um
you will receive um some additional
dates for special meetings of council.
These will be work sessions related to
um the writing of the administr of the
administrative code of the city. So more
to come to members of council for that
and thank you for your work.
Any additional council
comments? Right. Having reached the end
of our agenda, I will hear a motion to
adjurnn. Motion to adjurnn. Second. All
in favor? I I We'rejourned. Thank you.